Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
We just hit 5000 subscribers. More than five
thousand Fellow Scholars who wish to join
us on our journey of science. It really shows
that everyone loves science, they just don't
know about it yet!
About 6 months ago, we were celebrating 250
subscribers. The growth of the channel has
been nothing short of incredible, and this
is all attributed to you. Without you Fellow
Scholars, this series would be nothing but
a crazy person sitting at home, talking into
a microphone and having way too much fun!
Thank you so much for hanging in there! I
love doing this and am delighted to have each
of you in our growing club of Fellow Scholars!
We have also hit half a million views. Holy
cow! If we would substitute one human being
for every view, we would be close to 6% of
the population of Austria, or almost 30% of
the population of the beautiful Vienna. This
is equivalent to about 60% of the population
of San Francisco.
This is way beyond the amount of people I
could ever reach by teaching at the university.
It is a true privilege to teach so many people
from all around the world.
We have so many plans to improve the series
in different directions. We have recently
switched to 60 frames per second for beautiful
smooth, and silky animations, and closed captions
are also now uploaded for most episodes to
improve the clarity of the presentations.
We are also looking at adding more Patreon
perks in the future. There are also tons of
amazing research works up the sleeve that
you will see very soon in the upcoming videos.
Graphics guys, I got your back, machine learners,
this way please. Other spicy topics will also
be showcased to keep it fresh and exciting.
My wife Felícia is also preparing some incredible
artwork for you.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!